it didn't go so well for Gordon Brown he
wasn't really looking at their responses
and engaging he was just going tell them
about child care tax credits tell them
you know
hello and welcome to women with balls
where I Katie will speak to today as
Trailblazers my guest today began her
career working in finance but soon after
becoming a mother she had a bold career
change in 2000 she founded mum's net
I'll give you the most influential
online Forum in the UK designed for
parents many mothers mums that has 8
million visitors each month and 1.2
billion page views a Haven for women to
learn comment and exchange views on
issues from baby names to who they're
voting for in the next election to
what's just driving them mad that day
mum's net users have grilled multiple
political leaders first David Cameron
then Gordon Brown Ed Miller Band and
most recently Boris Johnson in the last
week's first Premiership so didn't go
particularly well celebrities are
featured too in the early years my
guests led her operations to young
mother in her spare bedroom now she runs
it from kentish town with 75 staff my
guest today is Justin Roberts the
suggestion thank you very much for
coming on the podcast pleasure
um to begin with we asked would you
describe yours as a happy childhood
um yes I think it was a happy child I
did I sort of remember being quite bored
a lot
um especially on Sundays
um I was the third child and my parents
both worked and I think like you know I
have four children now and I'm
definitely less attentive of the fourth
than I was of the first so I think I've
had a lot of freedom and Independence
um but yeah
um I remember being stuck in Surrey with
nothing to do a lot that was my biggest
memory and you mentioned that you like
like playing football growing up I was
yeah I was mad into sports and actually
I was kind of I got into football
despite none of my family really being
into football
um at the age of seven and became and
have been ever since a mad Liverpool
supporter so that was kind of here I was
this girl from godalming
um with that you're obsessed by sort of
Bill shankly and Kevin Keegan
um but yeah I did I also played an awful
lot of sport myself
um you went on to study PV at Oxford zoo
at school or you're like a straight A
student
um yeah I mean I was uh yeah YouTube
shoes or I wasn't a good teacher I
definitely wasn't that and I remember
disruptive featuring occasionally in my
reports
um but yes I sometimes joke I went to
PPE but actually I did PE in in sports
again at Uni so you know I didn't study
as hard as I I wished I had now
um and uh I often think what an
opportunity that all those great
professors and I really didn't turn up
for many lectures so I was on the sports
field
I always wondered I went to Durham which
was obviously not quite the same high
esteem but I thought Oxford it might be
harder to duck out things in terms of
the structure I think it is now but I'm
quite old
and that PPE is obviously the go-to
degree for politicians Liz trust the new
prime minister study PP at Oxford
um so did you have political ambitions
um I thought I was very interested in
politics but I always thought of myself
as a sort of an outsider looking in and
someone who is more likely to sort of
lobber stone into the pond than than be
one of the establishment as I thought of
them I was actually asked at one point
by the coalition government Nick Clegg
asked me to join the government and go
into the Lords and be a junior Minister
for families which I think was the last
desperate attempt from them as an
election loomed
um and I I remember asking him can I do
it part-time because like I'm I'm doing
mum's death and he looked a bit shocked
by that but I at that stage I thought
well it's not really me I'm I'm I'm not
really one to toe a party line
um so I suppose I I I yeah I I don't I
would never say never though because I
think as Things become increasingly sort
of desperate and polarized I think
sometimes you've you've got to you've
got to get involved
so so it wasn't right then but not but
there is a chance not ruling anything
out in the future
um and now so when you graduated from
Oxford you went to finance what was you
thinking there well it wasn't really
thinking I I got some work experience in
my second year which my mum my mum and
dad weren't really very well connected
but they had my mum had been a secretary
for a guy who ended up being chairman of
a bank Investment Bank and so I just
thought oh go and give that a try and I
ended up on the trading floor of the
stock exchange one of two women and I
sort of kind of fell in love with it in
in just in the sense of I guess a little
bit was trying to prove myself so with
with sort of no real vocation or clear
idea of what I wanted to do I thought oh
well I'll go and do that for a bit and
see what happens and then I spent 10
years doing it in various different
roles and I tried everything I was a I
was a Trader and then I was an economist
and then I was a strategist and then and
then and then and then when I realized
what I was really trying to find was the
right cultural fit which was going to be
impossible
so I would say I had some good
experience but it was it was a it was
not really me so what decade are we in
at that point we're in well that's a
good question so yeah it would be it
would be 90s yeah right so I imagine 90s
to be quite maybe I'm imagining like the
strip club era you were and right I mean
some Dreadful things happen I remember
going to a Chinese restaurant with a hot
plate and and these people were throwing
money onto the hot plate and burning it
I mean it was incredibly misogynist
um it was incredibly yeah a homophobic
racist over everything and I was just
trying to sort of prove that I was as
good as the guys and and I now look back
and thought think you know a little bit
regretfully that I didn't make more fuss
um I was just sort of putting my head
down and saying well I can do this but I
knew even though you will expect me not
to
um and then I went I ended up going to
America and working in New York on Wall
Street for a few years which was
actually a much better environment for
women because they they sort of yeah
they've been a lot of lawsuits and it
was much better for all minorities and
uh
um and and when I eventually came back
to the city I lasted about six months
because I could not stomach it anymore
um and so when you decide to leave the
city you obviously going to try
journalism but is that before or after
you start a family so yes both
um so I I left when I was pregnant
knowing I can't have a family and work
in in this environment because the women
who who had got on in the city had done
so by pretending no children didn't
exist really
um so I thought okay we almost seen
differently once you had a child in the
industry well they literally hid it so
they would work even longer hours never
go home never be there for bath time and
be more sort of masculine than the
moment sort of Margaret thatcheresque
really
um so
um when I got pregnant I I realized it
wasn't for me and I left and I followed
my passion which was football and to and
cricket and I started writing match
reports I sort of I went and did a bit
of
um I shadowed a guy who a lovely old guy
who used to write match reports and and
then I submitted some total times and
they said yes you can do this I think
actually probably quite helped by being
a woman because it was unusual and I did
that whilst I was pregnant with twins
which caused some consternation in the
in the Press Box and certain managers
were very rude
um and then afterwards when my when my
twins were sort of were you know up till
the age of three and I'd started mum's
death concurrently but I carried on
doing weekend match reports and why were
they rude just because they didn't think
you should be yeah no one I remember I
think it was Joe Royal who was the
manager of Manchester City said
literally you know you should get back
to the kitchen sink glove when I asked a
question and this was before ladet and
women had really got into football and
there were very few female reporters so
uh yeah and there was I with my enormous
stomach because I think they were all
very short and create space for yourself
you're doing it yeah
[Music]
um so uh you mentioned mum's not there
can you for listeners can I think
everyone has now heard of mum's net most
people have been on it but also just
Falls but if we rewind to when you're
just thinking about launching it how did
it come about when where did the idea
exactly come from well it was in the uh
you remember the sort of Gold Rush days
of the internet where everyone was
having a web idea so you kind of had to
have an idea
um and mine was that germinated from a
really disastrous first family holiday
so we'd taken our one-year-old twins
abroad and we chose everything wrong it
was the wrong supposed to be a family
friendly Resort and it certainly was and
it was the ROM Resort wrong destination
wrong time zone frankly the wrong
children and it was just the worst
holiday ever and everyone was around the
pool saying why did we pick this place
and my light bulb was yeah I would have
loved to have known before I'd gone from
other parents who'd been there and done
that and it's not just holidays sits
everything it's everybody we're not
trained to be parents and you've got all
these people who've been there and done
that and and got the baby sick on the
t-shirt and it would be nice to tap into
their wisdom and the internet was just
starting and seemed like the perfect
vehicle for that so that was the idea
and I was kind of in a space to come
back and try it because I'd left my
reasonably high paying job and I'd sort
of done my time my 10 years earning
money and I thought okay I can probably
take a risk and if it fails uh I'll I'll
do it in a nice way with my kids around
and I'll have a lovely you know family
first environment to work in it didn't
quite work out that way but but it was
uh it was a gamble I could take
um so at that point how did you go about
how did you go about from having an idea
to then actually getting the funding
setting up yes well it was getting it we
didn't get any funding so I came back
and I wrote in a friend from antenatal
class and I wrote in another friend who
fortunately had learned to code
so he was working full-time somewhere
else but in his evenings he he was able
to code a website for us
um and we went on the trail of raising
money and I had this business plan and
was asking for four and a half million
quid or something and luckily I think in
the end the.com Bubble Burst and no one
raised any money and that was actually
quite fortunate because the right model
really was organic growth from on a very
low cost uh basis because we were six
years before really Facebook arrived and
no one really understood
the um the social workers it's now
called uh and we all my business plan
was not worth the paper it was written
on and people were still on dial up it
took I remember doing I was an early
adopter of Internet shopping and doing
my Tesco shop and it used to take four
hours from start to finish so it was it
we were kind of a bit before our time
um and luckily we were able to do it
very slowly on very low cost you know
from a back bedroom which and build the
community while the sort of business
models evolved and during that period
how did you get people to join mums now
is it just kind of word of mouth
initially it was I mean it started on
the link having to message lots of Yeah
well yeah so it started off literally
with us going around to sort of uh I
know a one o'clock clubs and and baby
singing groups and and giving a pitch
and we were collecting reviews for push
chairs and things but uh but there was
this forum which we hadn't really
envisaged but um yeah the guy who could
go and said to me do you want a 4 and I
said how much is it and he said fifty
dollars I said okay let's have a forum
and I was largely talking to myself
under multiple nicknames asking lots of
questions luckily I had lots of
questions so would you reply to yourself
I would reply to myself with the
difference try and show this like
there's a conversation and
um and then eventually I remember a
friend of mine run me up and said she
was pregnant and she asked me whether
I'd had some symptom of pregnancy and I
said well yes I do know all about that
but I'm only going to answer you if you
ask on mum's net so I felt a bit guilty
and rushed on to answer her question and
two people had responded and I realized
okay the words getting out of it and I
was lucky enough actually to be asked to
write a diary of a.com startup for the
times and that definitely brought us
some users and but we've never spent any
money on Advertising it's all Word of
Mouth really and were there any points
in the early days where you just what am
I doing
um it did seem like well it was it was
always obvious once we began to get
people using it that it was useful and
uh and and literally people would say
you know this has saved my life because
it's helped me learn to breastfeed or
I've found someone else who's going
through the exact same problem as me but
the money thing really I mean we just no
one trusted the Social Web no Brands
were interested we were too small anyway
um and lots of people then were saying
the internet's a flashing the pan I mean
it's hard to believe that now but
um so it did seem like I'm not sure this
is ever going to make any money but it
was felt like a valid and useful thing
to be doing
um and then I I suppose at what point
then what are the Milestones when it's
suddenly actually it's really taking off
and you're like it's not just a nice
hobby yes this is now a business that
yeah I think two things happened around
about the same time 2006.
um one was
um we were memorably sued by the most
famous childcare author of the time uh A
lady called Gina Ford and that became
kind of Front Page News because she was
essentially suing us and threatened to
have us taken down and sued our ISP and
all kinds of things because of something
someone else said about her on our forum
and she was quite a polarizing figure
who caused quite a strong opinions in
mums
um and so it was kind of became a test
case for for the web and and uh
Publishers on the web
um and it sort of revealed that the
internet had libel laws hadn't really
caught up with they were still basically
seeing a site like Mom's dad as a
newspaper and that we had editorial
control over things so that that became
you know it was huge publicity and it
actually LED I think it led channel 4
news and things like that so we've got a
lot of publicity from that and then
David Cameron came on to do a web chat I
think it was the first sort of major
event he had after becoming leader and
so I think you know since then the mum's
net web chat the sort of rite of passage
of a politician
um has sort of become more established
and that's uh how did you convince him
to come did it take much convincing or
did he already was he already quite
aware of it it was actually I mean um I
think it was his advisor Steve Hilton
was very into uh not wearing shoes yeah
so you know the community has to give
real people
um I think they politicians are always
obsessed with getting the women's vote
because they view it as more of the
floating
um and he wanted to be seen as modern so
I'm a modern guy who understands the
internet and can engage with people
um as you mentioned David Cameron was
the first obviously like you know and
since it's become a bit of a rite of
passage and I think that um for those
people who perhaps aren't on Mom's lab
uh I think they've all read about mum
someone has known election and
um you know people I think it's gone so
far as you mentioned it's almost the
side of the floating voter for people
say you know Mom said can win or lose an
election
um do you think that's the case well
obviously you don't want to do down your
brand
um I think it is true that a high
proportion of
um female voters are less tribal and and
often more floating the what isn't true
is that there is a mum's net vote that
votes always this you know that all the
women or months that are suddenly going
to vote touring or labor
um we have you know we've got eight
million users and they are all political
Persuasions so
um you it's no there's no such thing as
you're going to win the mum step vote
but you are talking to a lot of women
who maybe haven't quite decided how
they're going to cast their vote so I
think
yeah it's not it's not going to decide
elections but I would think it's a valid
place to go and do if you're in your
election campaign to go and talk to this
constituency is not a bad idea and Rich
politicians do you think have uh done
the best or struggled the most when it
comes to their their time of mum's net
well the ones who do the best are the
ones that as I say show a bit of leg and
join in the sort of nature of the
conversation which is a 2 two-way
conversation in real engagement and not
just giving stock politicians answers so
uh who Springs to mind who's done that
well I think Michael Gove made quite a
risque joke that was quite fun for
people and what was that one again
is it appropriate to say on uh I'm not
sure actually I'm not sure if it is a
program
um it was
um but
um it was quite funny
um
but who else has done well
um yeah I think anyone who's prepared to
really engage and and
um
say things in an authentic way
um I think he obviously notoriously it
didn't go so well for Gordon Brown who
um came he didn't really understand the
format and he came with a load of
messages and he was broadcasting so
um and ultimately our users clocked onto
the fact that he wasn't really looking
at their responses and engaging and
that's why they asked what his favorite
biscuit was 12 times and that
notoriously then became biscuit gate and
David Cameron used it to say how
indecisive Gordon Ram was but it wasn't
that he was indecisive he just wasn't
looking he wasn't he just he was just
going tell him about child care tax
credits tell them you know
um so it's it's a test of how well
people engage with the medium really and
and he had a mum's net pole I think
during the Tory leadership and Liz
trusted did not come out on top of
something no she came bottom actually of
the five candidates that were still
involved at that stage
um and mercy sooner came second button
and I think that was partly because it
was a vote
against the current government I mean I
think people saw both of them as being
involved in what they thought
um was quite a yeah a bankrupt corrupt
party gate had just blown up we'd had
our interview to and and our users were
really angry about what they saw as you
know an abuse of power really
um for just asking you a few events at
the present day I wondered are there any
I mean we've all seen the news articles
done in senior which is just a very
funny conversation it's gone on a month
now
um Scarlet are there any particular
threads that you've um over the years
um found like the most like
quintessentially mum's net uh yes but
they're quite hard to sort of get across
in on on on a podcast or on radio
um I mean there's there's our users are
really really funny
um and I mean just they're very
quick-witted and and it's an odd thing
because people think mothers aren't
funny I mean there's just a you know no
one thinks their own Mother's funny and
what's up to laugh at
um and I think you know the idea that
middle-aged women can can crack jokes
but I mean there are lots of examples of
brilliant brilliant funny threads and
and a lot of talk about you know sex so
there was a pirate sex one and I know
the other thing people think women of a
certain age never talk about sex and
then how do you wonder how that can be
because we've all had babies so we all
must know about sex the the one I mean
the next example with the gina Ford
thing she was immediately Chris and she
who must not be named by our users
because we band or mention of her on the
forums
um there are there are all kinds of I
mean I'm not giving you a very good
answer
um there's a brilliant thread called
cutted up pear which is written
um it's of our users pretending they are
toddlers talking to and about their
mothers
um and it's like my mother's a very
difficult woman she insists on cutting
up my pair the wrong way and stuff like
that and it just goes on and on and on
and it's that's probably my favorite
yeah and where you wouldn't be able to
get it anywhere else yeah yeah no
absolutely not
um and you mentioned obviously sex but
one of the other things that's been a
news recently is related biological sex
at mum's net and so I think this has
been a fair bit on this but there is a
journalist for the New York Times who
wants pondering
um why the UK Elite has more turfs uh
then I was and consider that the answer
is mum's net
um what did you make of that
um I lit there are we've had a feminism
board on mumstead
um for I mean years for at least 10
years and on that board there are people
who discuss you know this issue um and I
think lots of women once they have
children become very aware of their
biology
um and and there are also lots of women
who are quite concerned about kids and
particularly medical intervention for
kids who are transitioning and stuff
like that so I don't think it's a
surprise that on a forum of you know
eight million women you're going to get
some conversation on this issue we have
chosen not to shut that conversation
down and I think that's
um I think a lot of other places on the
internet have have shut the conversation
down and we've done that because we we
have a value which you know we believe
that discussion of difficult and
contentious issues as long as it's done
civilly will lead to resolution or is
more likely to re lead to resolution
than just canceling the conversation so
we you know we have probably
um you know put ourselves in the
controversy because we've chosen not we
think it's part of our values you know
mum said it's about discussing things
it's about parents being able to raise
their concerns and as long as it's legal
and as long as it's civil then we would
find it very odd to shut that um so it's
kind of a bit freedom of speechy as well
yeah have you personally uh been the
subject of a piece because of that or
um I mean bits and Bobs not nothing like
I mean I haven't expressed my own
personal yeah
I mean you know obviously some people
are angry that we let that conversation
go on
um but I mean over the course of the 23
years now almost that mums that's been
going there have been huge amounts of
abuse I mean I've been I think I'm I was
the first person in the UK to be
officially spotted where people you know
um I don't know if you know what
swapping is but basically it's a thing
that Gamers do in the US where they call
the police and say there's a violent
crime going on in a house and the police
turn up with guns and dogs and
um yeah um it's a scary thing
um and I've had dirty Underpants sent
through to our offices by fathers for
justice type okay yeah
um so you know we are we're unique
really in in being a very busy high
profile place where women collect on the
web and it is mostly women and that
causes quite a lot of
um anger among some people is you've had
to develop pretty thick skin yeah you
have to yeah
um just to find a few very um last ones
one is um
just talking a bit about freedom of
speech there and I wanted the Online
safety bills obviously
um yeah a big issue at the moment
there's some questions as to what the
new prime minister is trust will do on
uh do you think that has a threat to
some of the conversations if it goes
through in its current form I I think
it's a very woolly notion of
psychological harm that that you know we
you're supposed to not cause
psychological harm and having moderated
a very busy Forum with loads of people
with
um you know lots of different ideas of
what causes them harm
um we are asked to make decisions on
moderation every day if we were to take
down everything that someone thought had
caused some psychological harm there'd
be very few conversations left on
Monster so I think that is Woolly and
it's in it's a dangerous thing that um
you could see that people would use it
to tie websites like ours in knots and
uh cause a lot of sort of legal cases so
I I'm quite worried about it but I do
think well I know because Liz trust told
me that um I met her on the stairs once
and I'd written a piece in the times
about this and she said I think her
words were just in you and I are in
danger of agreeing on too much
you need to get her on for a politician
I do I do need to get around well she's
been on mumset before it didn't it
actually didn't go so well
she was talking about child care ratios
it was her first aesthetic thing yeah
and uh I think there were 386 comments
on the thread and not one of them
supported her plan so yeah I think it's
fair to say she didn't win the argument
on that one on mum's net I think was
this when she was a junior education
yeah she still wants to do Child Care
ratios so hopefully she'll have better
luck if she comes and tries to sell it
more of an argument I don't know I'm a
little bit doubtful
um just final two questions as well is
um when it comes to the advice on the
forums do you use them for to get advice
ever or do you take the advice for your
own life I mean always I have but I now
I'm I'm now slightly dubious about
posting even though you can be anonymous
to my own team if they looked hard
enough they could find out what was me
so
um I'm more of a lurker than a poster
these days
figure lag is quite good and then the
final question is why don't we just ask
everyone who's been in this podcast
which is what is the worst advice you
have ever been given
um I think it's this
um idea that you shouldn't say if you
haven't got something nice to say don't
say anything at all which I think
um for a long time was sort of how I ran
mum's net as a business and I think it's
particularly destructive and we were we
were all really nice to each other but
no one was giving any feedback
um so no one really was learning and no
one was improving and I'm now sort of
um come to believe that and I think
women get told this a lot is that
actually you should be very forthright
with your feedback as long as you're
doing it in a kind enough way and I've
adopted this approach called radical
Candor and we all use it in um in the
organization and actually it helps
people improve and as long as you're
sort of generally caring personally
giving in the moment feedback
um in an effort to develop people and
improve people I think really helps an
organization so how do you do radical
Candor well I might say to you Katie
you're really good at this podcast but
the coffee is really not up to scratch
and then next time
the place wouldn't even be red
no it's about it's a it's about I mean
it's about viewing feedback as a gift
exactly you if you want to actually help
people but you've also got to remember
to do the praise thing too so I would
also say but by the way what brilliant
questions yeah what a great mug
[Music]
thank you so much for coming on today
Jesse it's been a pleasure
[Music]